Washington's ambassador to Berlin has
issued a stark warning to German
companies over a controversial pipeline
that would supply Russian gas to Germany
while bypassing Eastern European
countries
Richard Grinnell repeated reportedly
wrote to several companies involved in
the construction of the North stream to
pipeline reminding them of US sanctions
on the Russian energy sector Grinnell
also criticized the project on social
media the US has long opposed North
stream saying it undermines European
security for more now let's bring in our
political correspondent Simon Young hi
Sami so who exactly did the US
ambassador right - and what's in the
letter
yeah this is not the first time that so
the the US ambassador in Germany has
been making these public comments
criticizing the North stream - project
but this is the first time he seems to
have addressed himself directly to
German businesses like Ventus Holland
UNIP ever involved in this construction
and there are many other specialist
firms who would be difficult to replace
if they decided to to pull out as a
result of this pressure he's saying that
Nordstrom - because it increases German
and European dependence on Russian gas
that it undermines security in Europe
and Ukraine and he'd just give you
another quote from what he's been saying
mister Grinnell says I request on behalf
of my government your company consider
the danger this project represents to
European energy security as well as the
reputational costs and sanctions risks
associated with it so a pretty strong
language I think there from this top
diplomat now Nordstrom - this pipeline
project worth billions of euros it's
already underway constructionist is
underway why would the u.s. want to
impose sanctions on the firms that are
building it what does the how does the
u.s. stand to gain from that well I mean
the u.s. like some European countries it
has to be said has as I mentioned got
this criticism strategic criticism
essentially of this project they say
that it means of
Russia will have more power more
leverage it will operate to the
disadvantage in particular Ukraine
through which much Russian gas currently
flows to Europe and it will essentially
reward Putin's Russia as the Americans
see it for you know for the pressure and
the bad behavior that they've undertaken
recently it has to be said on the other
hand many certain many say that the
Americans are keen to sell their own gas
into the European market something
they've they've had trouble to do lately
because it's very expensive
ambassador Grinnell he has ruffled quite
a few feathers since taking over his
post here in Berlin this is not the
first time that he's drawn the ire of
German politicians is it that's true
he's irritated a lot of people for
instance he he said right back at the
beginning when he took over as you a US
ambassador here that German companies
should immediately cease doing business
with Iran you know that was a seen as a
really really serious intervention and
he's tweeted a lot of other things he
talked about you seeing his role as
empowering far-right parties across
Europe so certainly he's had some
controversial views as you might expect
from a close confidant of Donald Trump
Simon thank you so much DW political
correspondent Simon Young
you